for top mobile marketing tips for law
firms the legal industry can be highly
competitive making marketing one of the
most critical elements of success for
your law firm what that marketing should
entail has evolved greatly over the
years today's legal marketing programs
must integrate activities specifically
targeted to reach and accommodate mobile
users this includes people on tablets as
well as smartphones ignoring these
audiences will lead to disappointing
results so what exactly is mobile
marketing and what makes sense for your
firm the following are four recommended
mobile marketing activities that we
think fit that bill number one ensure
responsive site design first and
foremost you must ensure that your
website displays and operates seamlessly
and fully on any mobile device do not
force visitors to scroll side to side or
show them flash elements that cannot
play on their phones these experiences
will create quick results for sure but
those results will not be the ones you
want people will simply leave your site
and move on to your competitors site
number to optimize your site for local
search you know that location matters to
your clients when they are seeking legal
representation you must ensure that your
site and SEO efforts are set up to
capitalize on your location this
encompasses simple things like adding
your location to h1 h2 or title tags as
well as scattering location keywords in
your copy without making your content
unreadable one important note must be
made here do not overstate your
geographical reach if your firm is in
Riverside California list that rather
than the more generic Southern
California the more relevant and direct
your content is the better chance you
have of being returned in a search
appropriately some other activities may
be a bit more involved but can pay off
such as creating a schema markup number
3 target mobile users
with paid ads because people commonly
search for your services while on mobile
devices consider increasing your bids on
specific keywords for mobile searches
this can help you target mobile clients
more directly and compare your analytics
to see the level of traffic generated
from mobile more clearly to help guide
your ongoing efforts number four create
a useful mobile app there's been a lot
of discussion about the pros and cons of
developing a mobile app for your law
firm the bottom line is that these pros
and cons are no different than the pros
and cons for any industry the best
mobile app is one that can be useful to
the end consumer that is the most
inherent difference between a mobile app
and a website the app must provide a
specific function one example would be
an app that offers a calculator to
determine child support payments another
could offer a way for people to
determine estimated blood alcohol
content apps can also be used to
facilitate the submission of some
documentation or forms in addition to
the primary use of the app you can
provide directions to your office news
about your practice and details about
your firm's attorneys these are just
some of the ways that you can leverage
the importance of mobile devices in the
everyday lives of your clients mobile
phones and tablets have become virtually
necessities for most people today and
that trend is not likely to change this
delivers you new opportunities to reach
potential clients and stay engaged with
existing ones sign up for the newsletter
for more belief
you